tell me yeah how did you get to the 2.0
what did you learn
when you look at it what you experienced
from 1.0 and 2.0 you know
the quote i heard from rob connie is he
said that uh consumer heart
rob connie bear for shasta okay he said
uh
uh consumer hardware is the double black
diamond of stardust
as you said and you know and it doesn't
seem like that when you get started
you know you're on that news totally
right but it looks easy in a sense you
can take a step back and you know
you might even get people saying oh
shoot i you know um
i worried somebody would copy you or
something like that i'm like well which
one which one is it is it really hard to
do or is it easy yeah
so turns out it's really hard to do and
the reality is
the hardness is in the software so no
one has ever come back and said ah shoot
my plastic was really not working
you know like it's never that it's
always that you've created yet another
node of software so you get to your
normal user
and if somebody said i want to go make
an app and a private social network to
families no one would say that's really
easy they would say that's probably
going to be
some work and then add another node the
device that has to be
you know ever present and on and a whole
other software team that needs to work
on that thing
um so it actually is way way way more
software these
things you might have seen in this like
why don't you fix that feature why
doesn't that work better
they're always software things they're
always features that you'd sort of
experience in the app
what's changed though in the hardware
ecosystem in the world in terms of
building products
i remember in the first wave of startups
i invested in five years ago in the
hardware space
they just never even got their 1.0
product out they could barely get there
and then they all
underestimated what it would take to
ship and make the first products and in
fact
they sold their products so we thought
was very weird they gave a discount to
the indiegogo people on what the actual
hardware cost
so by the time it came out if they were
successful people were buying a lot of
them
and they were losing money on each sale
and they
underestimated what it actually cost to
make it yeah
yeah and all these companies got flipped
upside down totally and
you know i think there's there's a lot
to unpack there right number one is that
that yet describes more stuff hey i'm
doing a
a hardware start well look did you
really raise money for working capital
uh i think all of us go in it with the
expectations we're gonna do a pre-order
and get the working capital that way and
when you do the pre-order
um you know and i would even argue these
are the things that we even got into our
heads
okay well how sensational does this
video have to show this amazing product
for people that want to buy it early
right and and i even would argue a lot
of us were
you know uh things like uh what was that
flying drone that
you know swam in the water and then took
pictures you know there was
there was these incredible things that
were coming out that really
never did it almost set the bar higher
yeah so you know
our big takeaway was we realized that
and we did this by the way
that if we just subtracted about 75 of
our features
we were at about what the market wanted
right it wasn't about more features it
was about now that also feeds back into
hey
i want to get this to market if you're
trying to get every new feature you add
in conflicts with a previous feature or
another feature
right they're just going to start to it
creates another
place of a point of failure let's call
it and then how do you ship
right that's very interesting so to
rephrase that
uh a lot of the early hardware
entrepreneurs
over-promised and felt like they needed
to have every bell and whistle
to get somebody to pre-order when in
fact people just wanted something
elegant and simple
that solved a particular task and that
complexity
then drowned them in features and drown
them
in uh complexity than in the software
complexity and then
they never shipped or if they ship they
ship something that really wasn't
great 100 so less is more and you're
even taking out more features and making
it more affordable